all right so this week we saw that hate
trump destroy Trump mainstream media
blatantly rooting for the Democrats to
win in four days in case you missed it
well here are some of the examples if
you want a slight check on this man and
his unrelenting race to the finish year
to make sure he can continue destroying
this country you might want to vote Aldi
instead of standing up to this kind of
hate mongering by President Trump
Republicans are imitating it I know I
haven't stopped praying since you were
elected with reaction White House press
secretary the hardest job in the entire
universe
Sarah Sanders is with us good to see you
this went from look there's been
non-stop hate almost from the day
Melania and the president came down the
escalator but this took on a whole new
level this week racist Nazi comparisons
Gerber just never-ending
Lamy blaming the president for the
synagogue shooting and yet the guy that
shot up the synagogue and committed that
act of terror that an anti-semitic act
hated Trump because of his strong
support for Israel that's how bad things
have gotten
it's absolutely disgusting I'm just glad
to see there's no bias in the media
that's that's my favorite part of all
the clips that you just showed is they
constantly talk about how they're fair
in their reporting but what you just
gave us was a glimpse into everyday with
many in the media one of the Sabbath's
truths is that they want to blame this
president for every single problem in
the world but refused to give him any
credit for all of the success that he's
had it's absolutely outrageous and I
think you just saw a great taste and a
sad truth of what we we deal with
unfortunately every day you know you for
example you watch fake news CNN and they
deserve every criticism they get it is
almost every second every minute every
hour of every day that this is all that
they do is demonize the president and
it's not even deep it's gone beyond what
we get every two and four years racist
sexist homophobic xenophobic
Islamophobic dirty air
killed children and throw granny over
the cliff now it's responsible for
terrorism or some nut that that you know
sends bombs to innocent people one of
the things that I found so startling
there was a poll that came out just
today that showed over 60% of the
country feels like the media is dividing
the country and only 17% thinks they
actually do anything to help bring
people together yet they continue to try
to place the blame on the president
it is absolutely outrageous we saw CNN
the first thing they did after the
suspicious packages were mailed it
wasn't to condemn the individual it was
to go after the president the first
thing the President did was condemn the
individual go after that person at some
point Democrats and the media have to
put personal responsibility on people
that are carrying out these heinous acts
and doing these despicable things yet
they continue to want to try to put
every single bad thing in the world on
the president and it's just you know in
a weird way that it was funny to get
lectured by Jeff Zucker and I'm like
watch they own Network and you might see
you know the very thing that they
accused the president of but in a weird
way with the public 60-plus percent
seeing that the media is that way I
think they I don't think it means as
much and now the president's been on the
road he's doing 11 stops in less than a
week and the president's gone all in on
the campaign and I always believe the
polls anymore
because I think there is a incalculable
base of Trump voters that will never
talk to the media or any pollster
they're gonna go click and not answer or
lie to them absolutely and you can see
that at every one of the events that the
president's hosted not just over the
next coming days but what we've seen
over the last month it's unprecedented
the types of crowds and the people and
the enthusiasm that the president is
turning out particularly when he's not
on the ballot and I think that we have
great momentum going into Tuesday
there's great enthusiasm and the reason
is because the president has had an
incredible two years and people have to
make a decision do they want to continue
to go down the road that we're on under
the president's leadership
the booming economy one of the best
economies we've seen in years if not in
history is happened under this president
and that's because of the tax cuts
that's because of him getting rid of
this job-killing regulations that have
been a burden on businesses particularly
small businesses about that state years
all right we have 250,000 jobs by the
way and normally when you have a
hurricane that impacts job creation you
have literally wage growth the highest
since 2009 unemployment at a 49 year low
4.5 million new jobs since the president
was created we have literally 8 million
Americans off of food stamps and out of
poverty in that time and literally the
best two years economically that we've
ever had and yet I don't think I've ever
watched any one of the big three
networks the New York Times Washington
Post ever talked about what is really an
economic miracle and they all said it
couldn't be done and frankly Sean the
sad pieces I think a lot of people in
the media want to see the president fail
and it drives them absolutely crazy that
he continues to succeed week after week
month after month and deliver on things
they said that weren't possible under
any president much less under this
president and he continues to surprise
them all and I think he's going to do it
again on Tuesday whatever they pay you
it's not nearly enough I'd you couldn't
pay anybody I don't know why you do this
job I love how you treat and I'm proud
to serve in this administration I think
we've got a great story to tell and I'm
glad I get to do it boy that's what that
that's a great answer you serve in your
country though yeah this is you know you
carrying a lot of heavy backpacks out
there but Sarah Sanders thanks for being
with us
Yvette thanks Sean